all right how's it going everybody
it is a weird day it is january 7th
2021. this is the ruben report direct
message i'm dave rubin
and there's a lot going on here and i
was talking to my team last night
and i was sitting on the couch just
basically staring at the ceiling at
about 10 p.m
trying to process everything that
happened throughout the day and think
about what i want to talk about
how i want to frame it how i want to try
to help us
get through what i think is going to be
a
really insane two weeks until january
20th which obviously at this point is
going to be the inauguration of joe
biden
how am i going to explain what happened
yesterday
without excusing violence but also
acknowledging the very legitimate issues
of so many people
and all of that stuff and uh and i was
gonna write
actually a full direct message today you
know back in the day when the reuben
report started i used to do a weekly
direct message which was a five minute
video that i would write the night
before
and i would read it off prompter people
used to think that i was just doing it
off the top of my head
and i thought that was pretty amazing i
guess i could read a prompter uh
not too poorly but i they were written
and i started writing one last night and
then i thought you know what
this needs to be today's show needs to
be a little more than just what i'm
thinking about things it needs to be
what you guys are thinking about things
so uh i posted on reubenreport.com that
we're going to do and ask me anything q
a we got dozens and dozens if not
hundreds of questions on there
i've only taken a quick cursory glance
at them michael put the whole thing
together
and i'm just going to jump into them on
the fly and i'm just going to tell you
what i think and i think it'll be
probably cathartic for you guys to ask
some stuff
and share what you're thinking and for
me to just go
and just i'm just going to read them and
tell you tell you what i think for
for better or worse we're also going to
show you uh two
quick videos from the capitol yesterday
that are
absolutely worth seeing and things that
i don't think you're going to see
on cnn because it doesn't quite fit the
narrative
and as long as i'm allowed to be on this
youtube thing here
i'm going to try to bring you the stuff
that mainstream won't show you so we're
going to show you those
in just a sec but before we get to that
i want to talk to you guys about home
title lock you know i got a crash course
in home title theft
and you better pray that this never
happens to you because it can ruin you
financially
here's how the crime happens the legal
title to all of our homes are kept
online where they can be hacked
a cyber thief finds your home's title
forges your signature
on a quit claim deed stating that you
sold your home to him
then he takes out loans against your
home until your home equity is gone you
won't even know
until the collection calls pour in
you're not protected by insurance your
bank or common
identity theft programs home title lock
protects you
and in the unlikely event you become a
victim of home
title theft while a member home title
lock will spend up to a quarter million
dollars in legal fees to help restore
your home's title
go to hometitlelock.com and register
your address to see if you're already a
victim then use code
radio for 30 free days of protection
that's code radio
at home title like home title lock.com
and now back to me okay so i want to
show you two two videos here
uh these were taken by peaceful
protesters
at the capitol yesterday and and the
narrative that we're hearing from
mainstream media is that these were all
just violent trump supporters who
planned to overtake the capital and
there were
they were trying to go for a coup and
everything else now we've seen i'm sure
all of you have seen them and that's why
i'm not doing a
endless parade of all the videos of
people inside the capitol and everything
else today we've all seen them okay we
all get what happened
and there is 100 i want to be very clear
about this
100 uh without equivocation there is no
excuse for violence
politically over the last couple years
uh i have always condemned the violence
that has come out of antifa
and the left and black lives matter and
you can't burn down cities and you can't
burn down stores and you can't attack
people and stop
cars and stop traffic and all of those
things now i don't happen to agree with
their political positions but you can't
use
violence to get your political ideology
out there right
once you do that you've you've removed
all rules from a civil society
so without question i condemn the
violence but that doesn't mean that
that the good people who went there to
peacefully protest that they're all evil
and bad and everything else and then you
we all know what happens once a mob gets
together
individuals are good mob's not so great
so i want to show you two videos here
we're going to show them
i will show one then i'll come back real
quick we'll show the second one that
might give a little bit
of a different context than what the
mainstream media
is showing you so let's take a look
stop them
[Music]
okay so what you're seeing there is a
whole bunch of trump supporters outside
the white house uh sorry outside of the
capitol building
and what appears to be a bunch of them
yelling that an antifa member now i
don't know if he was antifa but somebody
who apparently is not a trump supporter
is bashing the window and they're all
saying no antifa they're trying to stop
him you can see people actually pushing
him
or pushing and pulling him away from the
window i think that's just worth showing
we know that plenty of trump supporters
went into the capital i am not denying
that
okay let's be clear i'm not denying that
and you can't be trespassing and you
can't be going into the capitol building
and sitting at
nancy pelosi's chair and opening her
mail which people were doing you can't
do that okay not good
but but cnn will not show you that the
new york times
will not write an article about that and
here's another angle of it that i think
even gives more context
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a whole lot of people cheering
when the guy is pulled away from the
window trying to stop him from being
violent and everything else now look
windows were broken doors were broken
into and once
they were then you can just see people
rush in that is what it is people
people did it without question and we
know that there was then violence
inside and everything else now what's
interesting to me is we i haven't seen
at least and hopefully over the next few
days we'll see it
so many of these people were unmasked or
you know wandering around with where you
could identify them one way or another
so i think we'll find out more and more
about these people um
i have no doubt that there were there
were plenty of trump supporters there
that were just absolutely peaceful
people
who are frustrated with the system and
went there to peacefully protest and
then again as i said once a mob
starts then people just start doing bad
stuff it is what it is anyway i don't
wanna i'm not sitting here telling you
it was all antifa
um agitators that got involved but it is
worth
seeing some of that stuff and i already
shared it on twitter and people are
calling me a
conspiracy theorist and a grifter and
all of this other stuff but
i think it's worth seeing and then you
can make your conclusion all right so i
want to get into some of your questions
as i said i took a quick cursory look at
them
um but i think i think it's worth just
kind of sharing we're all
we're all sitting in this weird spot
right now like everyone's looking at
yesterday going what the hell happened
what the hell happened
and uh and we got to try to make some
sense of it real quick though i want to
talk to you guys
about taser guys you know this is pretty
clear the world in 2021
can feel like an unstable and dangerous
place but we can't live in fear
taser is giving people the confidence to
protect themselves by creating
life-saving defense technology
the people at taser believe that safer
self-defense is better self-defense
tasers line of non-lethal
self-protection devices are small and
lightweight enough so you can carry them
with you
or in your glove compartment or your
purse yet they're powerful enough to inc
incapacitate the attacker they use an
electrical charge to immobilize
attackers for up to 30 seconds allowing
you time to escape
taser devices come loaded with features
like laser assisted targeting and
emergency dispatch which will send
response teams to your gps location
upon firing more than 237 000 lives have
been saved with the taser network of
devices apps and personnel
protect yourself and your family with
taser's line of smart defense products
taser is available without permit in
most u.s states get the taser
pulse plus or taser strike light at
taser.com
with promo code ruben save 15 now at
taser.com promo code ruben that's
t-a-s-e-r
dot com promo code ruben rgbin
restriction supply sea site for details
and now back to me okay so just one last
thing before i start this
you know the one sort of concrete
result since what happened yesterday is
not that uh
there was a coup not that somehow the
maga people took over
not that the uh empire fell or any of
those things
the one concrete thing is that facebook
as of this morning
has banned trump for the next two weeks
officially
and it's a little unclear to me whether
he's fully locked out of twitter right
now
or they're just taking down his videos
so even this morning
trump put up a video that i only saw on
rumble which was him
saying that we should have a peaceful
transition of power he's not happy with
the outcome and he's gonna
uh keep fighting in the future but that
he wants there to be a peaceful
transfer of power and that you know in
essence the the fight about the election
is over trump put that up you would
think that that should be up on
on the big tech platforms but they're
not even allowing that up so the the one
the grand take away from the events of
yesterday no matter what side you're on
is that we got more censorship today
that ain't good
okay so let's uh let's just jump right
in uh johnny says in times like these
it's important to remain
sane as you say all the time how do we
turn down the gas on the fire that is
the u.s
right now on a broad scale and in our
personal lives well let's do the
personalized one first you know i keep
talking about this idea
that you cannot be endlessly political
and it's so dangerous
that everyone all they want to talk
about wherever you go is politics and
all people want to fight about on social
media's politics
and that these these websites you know
like facebook
and places instagram is a really
interesting one a couple of years ago
instagram was all
food pictures right and then suddenly
instagram became all political facebook
which used to be about connecting with
your
your old friends from high school and
seeing kids pictures and
grandma was on there well then it all
became political and then you scroll a
feed
and it's like grandma picture trump
something burning
black lives matter uh family portrait
you know and it's like that's a crazy
way if that's if that's what you're
scrolling
i'm happy i'm sad i'm angry i'm nervous
like it's just a crazy way
to do things so i think we all of us and
i really try to do this
all of us should scale back our social
media use
that that does not stop the what i would
say is an actually systemic problem
that big tech is trying to manipulate us
and the powers that we are trying to
manipulate us
but that's at least one thing we can do
in our lives is be is get
off the hamster wheel a little bit and
by the way that's why
i do virtually all of my interaction
with you guys right now on
reubenreport.com which is my
my locals community we have a great
gated community of interesting people
and i communicate with people that are
all over the world on there and i talk
to people and they post things
we have live video coming pretty soon
we've got a couple great announcements
coming with the company
but that's where i'm doing and there's
no trolls and there's no bots in the
rest of it so that's where i'm doing
most of my stuff
i don't i don't do my instagram or
facebook
anymore i have guys that do it for me i
put the stuff out there right i have to
put the stuff out there as someone that
does
what i do for a living but i think all
of us you know separate a little bit
from social media and also like
focus on some of the stuff you care
about like you know lockdown
although it's not fun and it's actually
quite dystopian at this point
and pretty awful it gave us an
opportunity to like think about what are
the things that really matter to us and
i've started gardening more we've got a
rooftop garden now which i love
doing and i'm cooking all the time you
guys see i put up my steak
pictures there's nothing like taking a
freaking big ass tomahawk and seasoning
that thing
and and cutting it up and eating right
off the bone i mean i love it i love it
so i found some things that i'm into
playing a little music in the background
we try to music playing throughout our
house all the time except when uh when
i'm doing the show basically
um so i think you have to figure out
what are the things
that you can do with your family i got a
freaking there was only 500 bucks i got
a nba jam remember the old nba jam video
game
arcade game i got an arcade a stand-up
arcade nba jam
and i play my 10 year old nephew and he
usually beats me but i'm trying to get
better
like find some things that you can do
that make you happy to get out of this
now on the broad scale like
so now what you're talking about is like
on the political scale how do we get out
of this
and i think i had a few questions to
that were sort of around that
um i don't know what the answer is and i
don't think anyone knows what the answer
is
uh we have a seriously dangerous
situation on the horizon the democrats
in effect will be
completely in control of the government
because of the kamala
vp tiebreaker vote in the senate and
they are going to push
through all of the awful stuff uh you
know even right now they're the the
mayor of dc is calling for dc statehood
like they're gonna try to pack the
courts they're gonna try to get critical
race theory back and stuff
you're gonna all of the bad stuff that i
think all of you are worried about that
all of the people
who showed up in dc yesterday who are
upset
about a mainstream media that lies to
them and and calls everybody that that
doesn't
bow that isn't blue pill the conspiracy
theorist and a racist and all that stuff
all of it's going to get worse all of
it's going to get worse there is
no healing at the moment there really
isn't we have to find the places to heal
but i think that's something that we
have to do ourselves i don't think the
machine
is is ready for it yet so yeah but i
think there's going to be a few more
questions
along those lines andy says do you see
an alternative pushback media springing
up to the watchdog
machine and the legacy media i do
i mean look it's been popping up for a
long time but just this morning i got an
email from youtube
that in effect if you talk about the
election the wrong way
they're going to start giving your
channels strikes and i think they give
you three
if you get one strike on your channel
they limit some of your functionality
two strikes i don't think you can live
stream
three strikes they just delete you all
together so we know now that you know
as time goes on there will be more and
more things that you can't talk about
right they're not just going to say okay
here are the things you can't talk about
but we're never going to expand that
list once you say
all right we got a list of things you
can't talk about well okay we know that
list is going to keep moving
it's sort of like the alex jones getting
banned on things it's like okay you
banned alex jones
people can say what they want about that
but was it going to stop with alex jones
of course not of course not
um so it's it's really it's an odd
position that we're all
in right now we know how terrible
mainstream media is it is truly terrible
mainstream media
has been pushing violence right they've
been excusing violence when it was black
lives matter and it was antifa because
they like leftist violence
so all the last two years you've seen it
on cnn you've seen it on msnbc i
retweeted a video
uh this morning of a compilation of
things that have been said
about violence over the last couple
years um
and it's like they're at the top of the
video actually
uh is anderson cooper talking about all
the protesters yesterday and he's like
now they're going to go back to their
holiday inns
and their olive gardens and what he's
implying is yeah
you you backwards redneck middle america
losers like you you sleep at the holiday
inn and you go to olive garden now first
off the olive garden breadsticks are
delicious i think we can all agree on
that
uh but secondly anderson cooper his
mother was gloria vanderbilt he's worth
about 110 million dollars he makes about
12 million dollars a year
he is the elitist elite right he's loved
by the machine
and the way he mocks and the way that
the machine mocks
all of you guys all of us that's not
going to go away so i think the best
thing we can do is keep finding those
alternative voices i guess if you're
watching this you found me
but we're gonna have to take some other
protections because you know this isn't
like oh we're gonna
we're gonna just eliminate trump and now
everything's gonna get back to normal
it's like they're gonna still go on
witch hunts they have to find bad guys
all the time because otherwise
they'd have to look at themselves so you
it's on you to find some people that you
trust and then just keep finding them
because they're going to keep getting
pinned off emmy says is there a still
point to voting if the fraud is so
blatant and no one has the standing to
challenge it look
the irony of what happened yesterday is
had the had the violence not happened
had the
capital not been breached there was
going to be uh
a hearing on the and a voting
on the fraudulent issues right like we
were
they were going to talk about it ted
cruz was going to be up there talking
about it a bunch of them were going to
be up there halle
and a bunch of them were going to be up
there talking about it and unfortunately
we didn't get that
and then you know late night they just
went ahead and they and they did the
votes um
look a lot of people we know that at
least 74 million people
uh voted for donald trump right and then
something supposedly
might was it 74 million for trump can we
get the exact numbers at this point
let's get what the numbers that they're
telling us i think it was 74 million for
trump and then i think about 16 million
more for biden
it doesn't really make sense to me okay
i was right on the numbers not bad dave
um that doesn't really make sense to me
is it odd that on election night
suddenly eight states that trump was
ahead in all of them
that it all stopped like since when do
we just stop voting in the middle of the
night the
pipe that burst in atlanta and all these
weird things all these weird things or
something
we've all seen the videos i look like
you know people would say well it's not
widespread it's not
i don't know i don't know but i don't
think there's any reason
that we can't look at the systems we
have in place
and say can we make these systems better
and stronger by the way there were
plenty of democrats calling for that
after trump got elected right there were
plenty of democrats also
in the senate who were opposed to the
results of the election and trying to
figure out any way that they could get
out of it
so of course this is where the both
sides thing is is pretty awful
uh but ted cruz just this morning got
into it with aoc
who's basically calling for him to be
expelled from the senate
at this point and he's basically just
saying hey i just want to make sure our
elections are secure
it seems to me that if you don't want to
make sure our elections are secure the
only reason you wouldn't want that is if
you want to fix our elections
i will say one other thing on this which
is i guess the real risk right now emmy
is that what you're asking really is
when you say what's the point is that i
think an awful lot of people are going
to be black filled right now like just
put their hands up and be like man the
system
just doesn't work and that's dangerous
so you know you've got blue pilled which
is just like
you just believe everything the system
says then you've got red pilled which is
like you're awake to it
but then i think what happens to a lot
of red-pilled people is you can't take
it at some point remember that guy
uh in the first matrix there was the guy
what's his name joe palantonio i think
is the name of the actor
i don't know can you find out what his
name was in the matrix remember at some
point he just
the the machines basically make a deal
with him to kill neo because he's like i
can't take knowing the truth anymore i
just want to live in
a bliss when he has his red wine and his
delicious steak
and i think a lot his name was cipher in
in matrix thanks
um you should actually watch matrix
again
and it's an interesting character and
that's the idea of blacklist like i just
can't take it anymore i'm going to just
check out
and i think a lot of people are just
going to check out and i don't know how
you how you deal with that and look time
also will heal some of these wounds
so so we shall see sandy says have you
touched base with carlin borsenko she
was in dc
and has a balanced perspective on the
event as a whole not the fox or cnn
version i love
carlin number one she was in dc she was
texting me
throughout it um she uh
will be i guess we'll make an
announcement right now we're doing our
first
ever four person live stream
tomorrow at 11. i want to test this
thing out if we can start
doing sort of bigger broader shows with
a sort of faster
hot topic kind of stuff she will be one
of the guests tomorrow i'm going to save
the other two guests
in my back pocket for you but we're
going to be doing that tomorrow same
time zoey is 11.
i think carlin is absolutely fantastic i
think she was one of the all-stars
of 2020 someone who was a lifelong
leftist had a political evolution fights
for what she believes
and and even if i did not believe the
stuff that she believed the fact that
she's out there doing it and fighting
the mob i think is absolutely fantastic
uh so yes she will be on the show
tomorrow lin says don't you think it
awfully convenient that the deplorable
stormed the castle while all of america
was watching we never got to see the
election objective
objections i always feel like i'm
watching an illusionist yeah i mean i
sort of just addressed that it's like if
this didn't happen yesterday
then we would have heard the objections
by the way we would have heard the
objections
and then pretty much it was a far-gone
conclusion
that the objections would have been
noted right they would have wrote them
down in their little congressional book
and then biden still would have been the
president on the 20th so it's a damn
shame that we didn't get to to that
point so they
so they could have just been heard and
then we would have all had to take away
with it what it will
as you say i'm always i always feel like
i'm watching an illusionist it's like
yeah it kind of feels like we're all in
a game
it feels like we're all being
manipulated by big tech
and in a weird way that that the last
four years
kind of just led to yesterday like if
you think about it does
does it feel like that crazy that that
happened yesterday
it seems very odd to me that there was
so little uh protection around the
capitol
you know there's a video where basically
just police officers are just getting
out of the way and kind of letting
people in like there's a lot of weird
stuff there i'm not going down
all of those crazy roads but it does
feel like everything that that has
happened over the last couple of years
just kind of led
to yesterday it led to yesterday meaning
frustrated people it led to yesterday
meaning violence it led to yesterday
meaning a dishonest media reporting on
it it led to yesterday meaning trump
the president of the united states being
banned from facebook like the whole
freaking thing kind of led to yesterday
and today is sort of a new day
uh rachel says i heard that authorities
identified antifa members using face
recognition wouldn't this be the perfect
distraction from the left to keep
everyone from looking into the voter
regularities
well you just saw the video that i
played a moment ago and i did read an
article about that
there is a face recognition company that
has done some work and found
some people in the crowd that were
antifa
and we'll i'll look into that further
and maybe we'll talk about that tomorrow
um greg says is it possible that the
election was actually more or less fair
and that the hyper-vigilant maga
people on the right are overreacting or
is every
thing we've heard online up to now
exactly correct in the u.s is literally
descending into a banana republic
territory
uh it is possible that it was legit it
is it doesn't
feel right to me and we all saw some
things and it's hard for me to believe
that joe biden who didn't campaign who
had no enthusiasm who the lefty base
hated because he wasn't one of them
and all of those things got something
like 17 million more votes than barack
obama did last time
that seems crazy to me and all i had
said
since november 3rd is let's let's just
look at it let's just talk about it and
if it gets to the end
and the court cases don't go through or
the evidence isn't there then biden's
the president and
so be it sometimes in a democracy you
don't get what you want right
um as for whether we're descending into
a banana republic it seems like we're
descending into a banana republic either
way and i think what people are going to
realize
and i was saying this about the lockdown
back in april it's like guys you're
going to think that march was the good
old days well now we're
10 months off of that and between the
lockdown and what's happened politically
and everything else it's like those
really were the
if you could trade think about it this
way if you could trade this moment right
now
to just go back to the world as it was
in say february of last year would you
do it
and i think most of us would most of us
would so what does that tell you we're
on a train right now and i don't think
we really know where that train is going
uh candace says trump is out who will
the left brain
blame everything on now well the answer
is trump they will keep doing it they
will
say he set the stage for all of this
they need him
they need him they need him you know one
of the things i've talked a lot about is
that
all of these people who have gotten
everything wrong who've dragged us into
wars
and made all of these bad decisions with
all of our policies
they needed trump because it was like oh
maybe i've done some bad stuff maybe i
have maybe i have i don't really
acknowledge it but maybe i have
people say i do some bad stuff but
that's the real bad guy that's orange
hitler over there so they kind of needed
him and they always need him
they they need the scapegoat right
that's not a defense of everything that
that trump has done obviously um but
they need him so i would say
who will they blame everything it's
going to be trump it's going to be trump
supporters
his enablers um and they're just gonna
keep
keep basically taking your eye off the
ball and and that will be
one of the one of the biggest and i
think hardest pills to swallow over the
over the next four years although i
sincerely doubt joe biden will be
president for four years
because of his health and everything
else but whether it's biden or kamala
one of the the hardest things to swallow
will be that
no matter what they do the media will
always excuse it and they will always
say oh but that was because of what
trump did before
that's because of that the same people
of course who would never say that
if if the situation was reversed so that
that's going to be a tough pill as well
and if you don't believe me it's like
okay well biden's been the
president-elect let's say since
uh about november 7th or 8th that
saturday after the election
and it's like how many can you show me
any negative press the guy's gotten
from mainstream show me any thing from
the new york times from
cnn from washington post anything
negative about the guy
no you get glowing obscenely glowing
pieces
on both of them and we're just gonna
have to
we're gonna have to get used to that or
we're gonna have to ignore it or we're
gonna have to build in
new institutions which is something that
i'm more interested in than
most i suppose nate says at this point
are we not essentially living in two
different countries
realities how do we ever have faith in
our elections again
i don't know i don't know i do sense
that we really
are living in two different countries
and you know people will say okay we
really have to come together right now
and i by the way i highly recommend we
drop part one of my interview with tulsi
gabbard this morning it's our fastest
growing video ever in the history of the
channel
as of like an hour ago and i think tulsi
as i've said many times she was the way
the democrats should have gone
if there was ever a centrist democrat
left if there was ever a sensible
democrat a non-identity politics
democrat
someone that was proud of the country
that didn't want the government to do
anything
it was like tulsi could have been that
future for the democrats
and and they went against that and they
went with kamala and joe obviously
instead
um but you know we are so
i talked to her about this though this
idea that we have to come together and
all that
and we may just be at an uncomfortable
spot which is we have two ideologies at
this point that are totally intractable
and i don't even want to say that
they're purely political so i could say
okay well it's capitalism versus
socialism or something
but it's basically freedom verse state
that's where we're at it's freedom verse
state do you want to live the life you
want to live for yourself
with the with the risks and and flaws
and
and joys and all of the thing things
that come with that
or do you want to outsource all of that
to for a state to basically tell you how
to behave so that you
feel either safer or or you feel more
secure or something but you're also not
really fully realizing what you're
giving away in the process
those that ideology between freedom
and the state those are pretty
intractable
and we've done a pretty damn good job
for 250 years of balancing those things
properly
but i don't know that we can get to that
spot and it may just be that the blue
and the red
uh that that just becomes a more and
more important thing you know people say
it's so bad we have these blue states
and red states but
you know as long as we're not warring
with the states which
lord only knows maybe that'll be next um
the idea that you can live in a place
that is uh more in line with with your
beliefs is
is good um by the way i do appreciate
all the people who've reached out to me
i've had so many people reach out to me
welcoming me
in advance to florida real estate agents
reaching out i had someone offer for me
to buy their house like
i get your florida i get you i'm going
to go back next month i like you
amy says if the election fraud continues
to go overlooked at we likely can't win
them again how else do we get positive
change
and uproot the corruption i mean you can
see the theme here guys you can see the
theme
um again this is where i don't want
people to be blackpilled because once
you're black building you're like all
right the whole system is rigged against
me it's like
that doesn't mean that that isn't partly
true it doesn't mean that the system
isn't screwed up every you know the
irony is everyone agrees that people on
the left the system is awful people are
right the system is awful so
a lot of people agree with that except
that sort of
middle ground person that just kind of
loves the system no matter what right
who benefits from the system no matter
what but that's
that's an increasingly small amount of
people how else do we get in positive
change i'll tell you
there's only one answer at least for now
which is get involved in your local
politics do you know who your local
representative is vote for somebody that
is more in line with you who might fix
the pothole in front of your house who
might have something
to do with the immediate parts of your
life who maybe
uh you know know who your d.a is my d.a
here in los angeles is a bernie
supported nut bag who doesn't want
people to be arrested if they steal less
than 900
worth of stuff by the way guys we're
going to go to best buy after and i'm
going to steal a playstation 5 okay
with three games that'll keep me under
the 900. i'll pay for the last game if i
go right over for a fourth game
i'll pay for it um and you can you know
they're not going to arrest people for
prostitution and trespassing so that
means a prostitute can actually hop over
the fence at my house and solicit
prostitution
and they won't arrest her and then if
she resists arrest they want to arrest
her for that
it's important to know who your da's are
get back to the local stuff i think
that's the only
short-term answer and i know what a lot
of you are thinking well okay if we get
to all that local stuff and we do it all
right well what happens as the federal
government continues to encroach
on our states and our local rights
huge issue i don't know what the right
answer to that is but i'm going to keep
talking about it
uh over the next couple weeks and months
um
valerie all right it's another there
there's definitely a theme here guys
uh where the hell do we go from here
doom and gloom or is there hope for us
you know i always describe myself guys
as a world weary optimist
i'm world weary because i think i'm a
realist more than anything else like i
just kind of see the world as it is not
as i
want it to be and i suppose that's why
a whole bunch of people enjoy listening
to to what i'm saying
um but i would at the same time say i'm
an optimist because
you know over the course of time
horrible things have happened there's
there's been awful genocides there's
been wars
there's been the you know the litany of
horrific things that have happened
throughout all time and and humans
persevere
humans get through it humans fight the
bad guys
david beats goliath you know we always
have a chance
so find the things that make you happy
in the midst of all of this
and i think one of the things that i'm
going to try to do for the rest of the
year
is is find what those stories are and
find those things that bring us together
and not make this show endlessly
political too you know when i started
doing this
the direct message i started doing this
in september
and originally i was only doing it three
days a week and then because everything
was with the election was getting so
crazy we expanded it to five days a week
and you know i think of course i think
we've offered a little bit of sanity in
the midst of the chaos here
but one of the things i'm going to try
to do going forward is maybe we
won't always do it five days a week even
though i make more money
if the more we do it right but maybe we
won't do it as much and we'll go back to
three days or some days we'll do four
i think we're gonna play it on the fly
so that so that there's something bigger
than just
every day talking about all this stuff
and and i wanna i really wanna
i wanna keep finding businesses that i
can help uh finding
connecting with you guys doing more
reuben report movie nights like we've
been doing
and just finding other ways to to escape
the madness and i think we're gonna do
some dinner nights and we'll cook
together
and all of that stuff um and you've got
to figure out what that is for you
so that you don't get totally burned out
by all of this but we're in a weird spot
and by the way that's not me sitting
here waving the white flag right like
it's not me like oh god
everything's so terrible i don't know
what to do that's just like
i think we're all in this together you
know what i mean whether whether we like
it or not
we're all in this together this is our
country and it's our country if we can
keep it
and we have huge issues to deal with and
and
you know we're gonna have to figure out
a way to slide through
and finally since i didn't get to one
star wars question the entire time
although there were several
tony says i know you get 17 million
political questions so i'll ask you
something different should john
favreau and dave filoni be handed the
reins to all of lucasfilm
my answer to that basically is yes you
know i
finally in the last couple days got to
watch the last two episodes of
mandalorian
and spoiler alert so if you didn't see
it yet pause stop don't do anything
go away click over to an unboxing video
or
whatever you watch on the youtube um the
last two episodes of mandalorian were
fantastic i've told you guys i i haven't
quite
loved it um but i thought they were
absolutely fantastic
and to bring back luke for that cool
thing
at the end there to fight the the dark
troopers is that what they're called
was was pretty freaking awesome i have
no love for
uh what's his name mark hamill uh
because he's become you know just sort
of a far lefty whatever
so he sort of ruined luke for me in a
weird way but it was really cool to see
you know a post
return of the jedi luke uh fighting
again and then and then he takes
obviously baby yoda with him
it it sort of felt like to me that the
show should have ended right there like
that should have been the adventure of
the mandalorian
like it was like he had to protect this
kid get him to a jedi for two seasons he
got him there
it seems like the show could have ended
right there and then right at the end of
it
they did this little promo for book of
boba fett which i know is going to be
another
series but it's like they could have
just like spun it off to that because
now that boba fett's back he survived
the pit of sarlacc
people it had been a rumor for years but
it did come true and he killed
uh bib fortuna which is one of my
favorite star wars names he killed bib
fortuna
in that little uh preview there if you
haven't seen it yet all right guys
uh i got i got a bunch to do today uh i
assume you have a bunch on your plate as
well
enjoy the day don't go crazy and uh and
if you want to talk to me directly join
us at reubenreport.com
and as i said uh part one with our
interview with tulsi gabbard is up right
now
on youtube and our first four-person
panel show will be tomorrow
at 11 a.m and and you can always submit
questions for the next q a at
reubenreport.com
that is all goodbye